[Música]
la ubicación exacta de estas imágenes
aún no ha sido confirmada Pero según la
brigada número 35 de Infantería de la
marina es el pueblo de Store recién el
liberado por las fuerzas ucranianas
al principio el enemigo se resistió pero
logramos tomar la iniciativa y poco a
poco cazar por casa recuperamos el
pueblo va muy
activo
los rusos huyeron dejándolo todo atrás
es un desorden terrible
es una de las siete ciudades ahora
recuperadas por quieven la región de
dones después que las tropas ucranianas
recapturaran las tres primeras este fin
de semana
nescúcheme y maca rifka los primeros
avances territoriales ucranianos desde
hace varios meses desde que voló
Ski anunciara el inicio de la
contraofensiva ucraniana
hoy las batallas son feroces pero la
fuerza de nuestros soldados da
resultados y doy gracias a todos y cada
uno de los que actualmente están en
combate por su parte el Ministerio de
defensa ruso afirmó el lunes que sus
tropas habían repelido los intentos de
ofensiva ucraniana las regiones
suroccidentales de doniasquiza por ella
y neutralizado objetivos con misiles
lanzados desde el mar